Ken Martin would be considered a primary source because he's
the DNC chair. So, he would >> Oh my god, he's just asking
questions. He's just asking questions.
>> But, if this was if the political teams were changed
here, Fisker would be like, "Epic. He owned him. Oh my god, he
owned him so hard, bro. He owned him with the facts there." >> He
couldn't even make an argument. He just said "Kamala." He basically
just said "Kamala" and then gave up.
>> I don't think Fisker does it intentionally. I just think
he doesn't have the political savvy to understand what he's watching.
He's not sophisticated enough to understand
DNC chair, Ken Martin, grilled on why he won't release the autopsy.
This is of course the 2024 DNC autopsy to see why they lost,
right? They did this autopsy. They would normally release it.
They didn't release it at all. Okay? So, people are like, "Wait,
what? What? What did you find that's making you hesitant to release
this?" >> I want to start with the 2024 autopsy. Um when
you won the chairmanship in February of '25, you criticized the
DNC's refusal to release their 2016 autopsy as exactly what not
to do. You said, quote, "Was there any utility in doing that?"
and then promised your 2024 autopsy would be different. Your
exact quote was, "Of course, it will be released." Why did you
change your mind on that? >> I don't know about you, John,
but I don't have a time machine. I don't think you do. No one
does. So, we can't change what happened in '24.
>> Nobody got a time machine. Okay, then why even do an
autopsy? Is there any way to read this now other than the report
is critical of Kamala Harris and they think it'll interfere with
their 2028 election Real quick, as we're getting into this. This
is Ken Martin. He is the chair of the DNC, okay? If you guys
weren't sure who Ken Martin is, this is the chair of the DNC.
Jon Favreau is a former Obama speech writer. He was in the He
was in the Obama administration in some fashion, okay? That's
him and a bunch of people who run Pod Save America, which is
a podcast network. It's a bunch of old Obama staffers who have
come together to create a media apparatus. Favreau has been about
the 2024 campaign and he's been explicitly like frustrated with
no basic nobody's like said the exact mistakes. He's been He's
been commenting on it for months. And he's not like a leftist,
he's not a populist. He is an Obama stopper. He's like a neoliberal
at heart. That's who he is. >> I appreciate this. I think
we should be able to do these types of interviews. I think this
is good journalism. But it only ever happens against the center
left. Only always only and always against the center left. Look,
where the [__] was any of this with Hasan? So Hasan,
I see here that you said you wanted to that every Zionist inbred
is a pig.
>> So like this has nothing to do with Hasan and he's just
he's mad that Jon Favreau wasn't harsh on Hasan. Broadly, what
I'm concerned about here is is Destiny seems to be seems to be
really obsessed with like Hasan and lefties right now, which
is fine. It's not like a It's not a criticism so long as it doesn't
affect the coverage. But he reads so much of the criticisms of
like this cabal that he thinks like me and Hasan are in and and
just overall Hasan saying he's in ascendancy. He reads all of
that into the analysis here and it makes it make no sense at
all. Okay, so then he gets onto the Pisco stuff. >> the
whole thing. >> So here's the Pisco interview or Pisco
review of the interview. >> Oh, we just watch the whole
thing. I don't need to watch him watch the whole thing. Let's
see what part of the slop cycle Pisco is on.
>> I can't imagine anything more slop or more populist
coded than trying to take this Jon Favreau interview and make
it about lefties.
It's so offensive that he's trying to paint Pisco as like a populist
or lefty.
And Desti's the first who's making this interview about lefties.
>> He's almost pseudo blaming the Pod Save Bros for like
a future Democratic loss or here on Favreau. He's like, "You
don't want to be the reason we lost, right?" It reminds me of
the people who said, "Don't criticize Biden. Don't call him Biden
a drop out. Don't you know, you're just ruining his chances."
And the implication here is like, "See, you don't want to lose,
do you?" And it reminds me a little bit when I'm criticized for
good faith and good criticism of this party, which is the only
vehicle by which we defend our country, the Democratic Party.
When I have good faith, good criticism of Democrats, then they
say I'm trying to sell Democrats chances. So >> Uh Desti
cannot compute. Wait, who would ever do this to Pisco? Who would
ever do bad faith criticisms of Pisco?
This has never happened to Pisco.
He's doing the Tucker thing. He's doing the Tucker thing. I would
never say that, Pisco.
Pisco, nobody would ever do that to you. Can you find me a single
example of anybody ever doing that to you? >> This is especially
triggering for me on a personal level. Time is exactly what I've
been saying now, which is we have to focus on the things that
help us win the future elections. We have to focus on those lessons.
We have to do this exercise, by the way, of doing of conducting
this analysis so that we actually learn what happened, not just
in 2024, but in the years preceding that election. And so, that's
where >> I don't know if Pisco will come out and openly
say it. I'm sure on the Majority Report or Hasan they they will.
But, the reason why, and Ken knows this, and John probably knows
it, too. He's just being a disingenuous little [__]
snake here. Everybody wants to see Palestine in that report.
They don't care how much it's there, if it's even listed a single
>> That's not what John wants at all. That's literally
not what John wants even a little bit. It's so funny. He's This
guy's got Israel-Palestine on his brain. He He desperately desperately
wants that report not to come out. I assume Now, I'm like trying
to think of why he wouldn't want it to be the Israel-Palestine
thing. I guarantee you, I know exactly what John wants. John's
talked about it multiple interviews, multiple times he's spoken
on it. He is upset that the Biden campaign staffers lied to everybody,
said Biden was doing great, and he found out that was a lie,
and it cost him the election, and he wants heads to roll for
it. He does not want these people involved. He thinks they are
incompetent losers who will do anything to keep the power they
have, and he thinks they're a cancer in his party. And he's probably
right. It's nothing to do with any of the Israel-Palestine stuff
that you're desperately I I assume it's like, "Oh, Hasan's going
to hold that up and say I was right." And I assume that's what's
dominating Destiny's mind here, and it is ruining any attempt
at understanding what's going on.
>> It's going to power that whole asspain movement for
another uh, 6 months all the way up to the election. And they
need the energy cuz people are kind of dragging a little bit.
They need They need need need need need that energy. That's what
they want to see so much. The challenge is as an executive summary
of the, you know, like I said, a 200-page document. And I think
what we put together and what we learned >> They didn't
release an executive >> Wait, I can't even understand what
>> That's where our focus is. I mean, you know, the challenge
is, you know, think about this as an executive summary of the,
you know, >> An executive summary summarizes the report.
You're saying lessons from the report. You're not saying that
it's characterizing the report. These are additional kind of
normative statements
that are derived from unspoken facts, perhaps somewhat contained
in this
Yes, it's a narrativization. When you say, "I'm going to give
you the lessons," it's a narrativization, right? That you don't
want. You want the facts because, again, for Jon Favreau, he
doesn't trust these people. He thinks they're incompetent. For
Pisk, for Hasan, he might want to say like, "Hey, I don't know
if you guys are going to be honest about Israel-Palestine, so
I don't just want an executive summary. I want everything you
asked." Right? That could be true for Hasan, but it's not what
Jon Favreau wants. It's not what most people want. Most people
want to know what went wrong. Tell me what went wrong or give
me the examples of what went wrong so I can look at it, validate
for myself, right? And everybody agrees, including the entirety
of the pundit class, the entirety of the um the the advisor class,
the donor class. Everybody agrees trustworthiness, trust is a
core DNC problem right now. Being this
lacking in any transparency,
is a massive issue. It's a massive issue for donors. It's a massive
massive issue for voters. It's a massive issue for analysts.
It's a massive issue for like staffers and the what would you
say? The um like the DC aristocracy types, right? It's a massive
issue for everybody.
>> Which is not being summarized by the lessons. So, it's
not like an executive summary, at least how >> This is
I don't know why Ken Martin, I don't know what he's read or what
his background is, but it's I I wouldn't characterize releasing
lessons from what is an executive summary. That's I don't know
why he's saying that. >> And I think what we put together
and what we learned, uh we are sharing with people so they have
>> Who? Isn't that the whole
>> So, you are sharing it with people. Full insight into
what we actually >> Well, he's sharing the lessons or whatever,
just not the report itself. >> To course correct on as
we go into these final 100 >> Or you're you talking about
the lessons again. It's so unclear, man. I >> He's talking
about the lessons. It's not >> They have nine days left
and into the future. So, again, >> Are you going to release
You mentioned an executive summary. Are you going to release
an official executive summary? Make it Make it a whole book.
>> We've been releasing that, John. That's >> We've
been releasing it like it's an ongoing process of releasing the
executive summary? Where is the executive summary? I miss the
executive summary.
Are you just like lying Are you just using different definitions
for words?
>> Yeah, he is lying. Piskopos got it. He's just lying,
right? He's just lying and trying to get out of this interview
without agreeing to anything. He's just lying. It's just a lie.
It's just a trying to fudge thing fudge the facts, fudge your
statements until you can get out of the interview and you don't
have actually acknowledge the fact that you're entirely going
back on your campaign promise. >> I feel like I don't know
what went wrong and what went wrong in the last couple of elections
in 2024 and figuring out what went wrong based on a big report
is pretty important for everyone to nail. I've spent my my entire
career, John, as you know, since 1990 winning elections up and
down the ballot both in Minnesota and across the country. I appreciate
that. And I'm happy I'm happy to talk to you about winning elections.
If you want to actually talk about elections, I'm happy to talk
to you about those. >> This is like super aggressive.
>> Who from He means from John, right?
>> Yeah, I see how people think this is aggressive. I don't
know. Did Piskopos miss the part at the beginning as well
where John explicitly says, "I had criticisms for you, so you
came on to talk to me." >> Oh, shot. Is he saying which
is funny cuz this is the exact opposite criticism I had of Ken
Martin. Ken Martin is way too um meek in this conversation. He's
way more aggressive. There's no way
that Piskopos is saying that Ken Martin is being too aggressive.
>> talk to you about winning elections. If you want to
actually talk about elections, I'm happy to talk to you about
those. >> This is like super aggressive. This guy hates
Jon Favreau. >> Does he's going to emote for the
Uh they do dislike each other. They very obviously dislike each
other. Jon Favreau's been mad at this guy, right, for a while
now?
But again, this is this is the idea that and this guy This is
all premised on some fundamental concept that Ken Martin would
have expected, if he's going on a Democrat podcast, to get a
soft interview. That is not the expectation from Ken Martin,
okay? Ken Martin's expectation is he's coming on to fight with
this guy. He knows that that's what he's coming on to do. He's
probably coming on to do it because he knows that he's amidst
rising calls for him to resign.
That he is having a hard time keeping the party together. That
when you're 6 months out from the midterms and your bank account
is negative
as in you don't have the money to run ads. You don't have the
money to run your campaigns. You don't have the money to door
knock at the most crucial times. When that's the case, everybody's
terrified. That's why Jon's mad. That's why everybody's
>> This is also why I'm saying because of how these like
medium cycles work, you should not be charitable to any of these
people. You don't get anything for it. You have to understand
the types of
>> Another classic example of the way Destiny looks at
the world. Don't be charitable. You're not going to get anything
for it. Uh-huh. Okay. >> And people like Pisco don't have
the media savvy. I don't think Pisco does it intentionally. I
just think he doesn't have the political savvy to understand
what he's watching. He's not sophisticated enough to understand
politics. Yeah, at this level. People like Hassan >> Pisco's
just too dumb to understand what's going on here. Pisco's just
too dumb to participate. Pisco's just really dumb. Has anybody
noticed that Pisco's just like a really dumb guy who probably
shouldn't be talking about any of this >> And the majority
report, they absolutely know what they're doing. Well, I say
that to be fair I haven't watched their thing yet. My predictions
on how all these cycles I break could be completely totally wrong.
And maybe I'll be pleasantly surprised. But the
Yeah.
Yeah, and I'm happy I'm happy I'm happy to talk to you about
winning elections if Yeah, but this is one of the issues that
you run into is if you're not aware of how these of how this
structure operates and you step into a hostile interview >> Just
in case I didn't get it for you guys. In case we weren't right
there. This is how it starts off, okay? >> Quick bit of
context for listeners. This all came about because you expressed
some frustration about criticism of the DNC coming from our direction.
So I appreciate you coming on to talk about it directly. >> That's
that's it, right? You were mad that I was criticizing you. so
you came on to talk about my criticisms of you. That is the entire
structure impetus for this conversation. It is not a neutral
conversation. It is not a Slotkin conversation. Referencing Breaking
Points and the Slotkin interview is stupid. You look like a complete
[__] bringing that up or trying to compare
>> expected to be a friendly interview. You you can't to
is if you're not aware of how these how structure operates and
you step into a hostile interview and you expect it to be a friendly
interview, you you can't win ever. You're only going to >> So
Destiny, by not paying attention at the beginning of the conversation,
has reached the conclusion that Pisco is not sophisticated enough
to operate in the space because he doesn't understand that Ken
Martin's getting like totally ambushed here. Ken Martin has no
idea what this is going to be. And all it is is he's playing
video games instead of listening. He doesn't care about being
accurate. He just wants to attack Pisco. He is a completely
deranged loser. He has no use, no purpose. The only thing he
has to offer anybody is an audience of drooling zombies who will
go out and knock on doors. I can't imagine how terrified anybody
would be to get knocked their door knocked on by these people.
It would be like you're in an episode of The Walking Dead, okay?
They'd like They'd be turning the door handle.
Brains, okay? Be terrifying, but He has people he can organize.
He's got money. He's got people who will donate. But there is
no mind there. There's no political analysis. There's no political
philosophy. It's just him being fueled by spite for people like
Pisco, people like Hassan.
It's not an honest
It's It's not an honest application of his platform. It's not
an honest use of his platform, right? He just wants to attack
the people he dislikes.
Also, this would be a perfect time to bring up how he does Pisco
and how he likes to project a lot. There's a a segment from last
night that I need to play real quick as well. >> on a big
rake. Like this is this is a massive cell phone like putting
out a memo that's like people >> Is him trying to drive
a wedge? Yes, of course. He has to watch it. He's got to >> So
he's talking about Hasan trying to drive a wedge between
these guys or him and these guy? I'm not even totally sure. But
he's talking about Hasan driving a wedge.
What is Destiny trying to do? >> Is him trying to drive
a wedge? Yes, of course. He has to watch it. He's got to support
the pro-Hasan element. It's
I hate that you were talking about this. We should watch every
single accusation that like Just a Gold in that crowd and everybody
have always made towards me and then I guess Hasan has echoed
a lot of these, too. And then know that that's their plan. That's
what they do, right? So the accusation was always that I was
trying to isolate people and reward people for being loyalists
and punish people for being dissenters and all this. This >> Yeah,
I don't know what you would call this, him his reaction to Pisco,
if not punishment for dissent, right?
And I'm not I'm not making that argument with no proof. I'm just
literally pointing it out to you that that's obviously what he's
doing in this case.
I just yeah, it's a it's total projection. It's crazy. And I
won't even say that I'm not covering this cuz it makes Destiny
look bad. I I was personally offended at just how bad the analysis
was. That's honestly what pushed me. If I just thought he was
attacking Pisco, I was aware he was attacking Pisco 3 days ago.
To be perfectly clear, I was aware he was attacking Pisco. I
didn't jump up and go, "Oh, for Pisco's honor." No, I didn't
give a [__] actually. And then I listened to how
stupid he was in attacking Pisco and I was like, "Oh, this is
too offensive to let go. This is actually too dumb to let go.
I can't I can't let it go. I got to I got to actually listen
to this [__] on stream and point out to everybody
in just how bad it's gotten. Just how bad You You have no idea
how bad it's truly gotten at this point. >> This guy hates
Jon Favreau. But again, you're proving a point that that. many
folks I think are frustrated in this party, which is people want
to turn backwards to >> Oh my The The people who are frustrated
right now is the Democratic base who sees our leaders doing such
and not being upfront with them, whether it's Schumer on these
shutdowns and the secret conversations he's having, maybe on
on being okay with the shutdown continuing, maybe not, whether
it's >> Oh my god, senators are talking behind closed doors.
Schumer needs to get on Zoom right now. Why isn't Schumer in
the goddamn Discord chat telling us all what's going on?
We need to have >> to be live tweeting >> to have
a Discord chat? Schumer's not live. Where >> Like the performativity
here, right? This is what I talk about sometimes when Destiny
has to make a point someone else makes, like super hyperbolic.
Like he just has to be very hyperbolic about it because he can't
engage with and and argue back against Pesca, right? He's not
interested in engaging with the idea Pesca's presenting of Chuck
Schumer possibly being more transparent. I'm sure Pesca has some
grounded reason for why he thinks that's important, right? But
we don't want to do that. We're just going to start like sperging
for no
Just totally sperging out for no reason.
Like I might actually be interested in hearing him try to argue
back against Pesca and the things Pesca's saying. But he's not
even attempting. He's just sperging out. It's sad. >> Where
is the stream? I haven't seen Schumer turn his stream on in weeks.
I need to be informed on what's going on right now. >> being
weird about votes on the War Powers Resolution, not being clear
with their voters, being cringe as [__] or whether
it's the DNC not releasing this autopsy and only releasing lessons.
That's what If you ask any Democratic loyalist, your base, your
supporters, the people >> base and supporters and loyalists,
he means all of the commie weirdo [__] that have
become obsessed with Follow the Yes. That's the only thing he
means, of course. >> who are championing this cause, trying
to defend this country, who are they more frustrated with? Jon
Favreau or you right now? There's not even a question in my mind.
I >> Most of them probably have no idea who Jon Favreau
is, not to be mean. Most of them don't know who I am. Most of
them don't know who Hasan is. Most of them have no
Pod Save America. Isn't Pod Save America the like center-left
podcast that
>> And just giving John the runaround. Just be direct.
Be clear. And if you can't be, level with why you can't be. I
can't disclose because that would do this.
>> He's already said that, but you don't accept that answer.
>> No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, Pisco's saying
I I think Pisco's implying there could be a contract with the
person who did the the study that prevents him from
It's not like give me a reason that's oh, I just I think I you
should listen to my lessons, right? That's not real. That's not
a real thing. And if it is, that's a stupid reason that everybody
disagrees with, right? I think Pisco's saying if you're contractually
obligated to not release it if the person who did it like if
there's some private agreement, then I guess just say that and
then we don't have to worry about
Pisco is looking for Ken Martin to say that Netanyahu
and the rest of the the rest of the
>> I guess Pisco's like anti-Semitic now,
So cool. I guess Pisco's also anti-Semitic now, guys. >> a
call and the APAC money came in and told you guys not to talk
about
That's what Pisco's looking for. That's what he's waiting for.
No other answer will suffice.
>> That's not what Pisco's looking for at
I don't know what you're basing this on at all.
He's just totally made this up. I It's very confusing.
sorry, I should say it's it's not really confusing cuz I went
and watched how he was talking about it. It's about Hasan. That's
what it's about. He's making it about Hasan. He's making it about
lefties, and it's not. And that's not what Pisco's I don't think
that's what Pisco's thinking.
To be honest, it's it's much more for John Favreau about something
else. And I guess John Favreau should be aware that Hasan will
say something about this and change his message up a lot based
on I don't I don't get it. Like that's the best case scenario
with Destiny's arguing here. I think he's going way beyond that
and saying it's like John Favreau's compla- complacent or, sorry,
implicit, rather. I think he's saying that John Favreau's complicit.
I think he's made that implication multiple
But, at best, it the steel man or the best argument he could
make is, "Well, he needs to know that some people like Sam Seder
and Hasan [__] will use this to talk about Democrats."
And I can guarantee you that John Favreau knows that and doesn't
give a
Like, he doesn't care one iota. It's only Destiny and maybe,
maybe, maybe downstream Hutch a little bit who think, "Oh, we
have to stop the lefties at all costs." Nobody else cares. Nobody
else gives a [__] Everybody who controls anything,
they don't give a [__] They don't think it's important.
He's just screaming into the the ether. And trying to drag Pisco
down, right? Cuz Pisco does have a lot of audience overlap with
Destiny, still. And Destiny's very focused on this guy before
he can build up more of an audience or more of a following.
I'm just I'm just telling you, that's like very obvious on its
face. There's no reason to watch this and try to tie Pisco in
with all of the people Destiny's audience hates, knowing that
they have overlap, knowing that Pisco obviously is like a massive
liberal, that he has major disagreements with with communist.
He just thinks it's not important to fight them right now.
That's the only difference. And he will Destiny will constantly
paint that as Pisco is pro Hasan, Pisco is like in bed with Hasan.
It's very sad. >> suffice at this point. >> can't
say that because that would make them, I guess, look bad, right?
So, we have to make a negative inference. >> It's not civil
court. >> Okay. You don't have to >> assume that
he's lying. Like, could we not fathom reasons why we really couldn't
think of a single reason why maybe it wouldn't be a good
Not to say that And also, I'm not a Ken Martin, okay, suck up.
Listen, I had this guy's interview because Pixie decided to drop
meme stack about me the day that I was supposed to interview
this guy. So, I'm not even a Ken Martin stan, but I'm just saying
we really >> It's It's actually crazy that people have
all decided that Pixie's evil.
Like Wick, Mouton, all these people. They just decided Pixie's
evil. It's It's actually kind of crazy, man.
He lost the connect? Well, Pixie dropped her her sub stack. Yeah,
yeah, yeah. And then he was supposed to be doing the the DGG
stuff in New York with Pisco. The Pisco set up, by the way. By
the way, oh, man. Pisco has every right to actually be pissed
at Destiny in a way that's like super spiteful and he isn't.
Pisco just wants like peace.
Well, when you think about it, Pisco set up all these DNC chair
interviews in New
he set up a studio.
And Destiny [__] it all up.
Right? Like Pisco probably had a lot of his networking, a lot
of his future [__] up by Destiny. And Destiny doesn't
see that at all, doesn't care about it at all, doesn't feel bad
about it at all.
And now he's like trying to [__] with this guy.
Oh, it's
It's It's actually crazy when you when you run it up when you
put it all together, it's actually pretty crazy.
I'll be honest,
far more disappointing to me
than um far more disappointing to me than Pisco's lack of spine
or
or Soy Pill's lack of spine is actually
Josiah being back in DGG chat and sharing links with this guy
despite what he's trying to do to Pisco in the
Like Like that's actually so much more disappointing to me. Like
it's not even close cuz Josiah actually had a lot of respect
for. I have a lot of respect for
But it's It's just that's so much more disappointing to me. I
just thought I thought he was so much better than that. It's
very sad. Does Josiah know? Oh,
Josiah knows everything.
They They all know everything.
I Like And it's By the way, I don't even have a problem with
them like sort of
with the the stuff. Actually, it's not even the Pixie stuff.
It's to me, it's what they're doing what what's happening to
Pisco, how Pisco is being like put under a boot. He's got a boot
on his neck. And these people all are friends, I think far closer
friends with Pisco, and they're not like paying attention or
watching. That's That's the thing that bothers me is like that's
something you can observe in the moment.
Maybe maybe they're unaware of that Maybe like Just Saiyan Soy
Pillar unaware that Destiny's trying to put a boot down on Pisco's
neck. You just take a negative inference.
You are not aligned with the Democratic base or or that you think
that um the DNC chair head is not aligned with the Democratic
base. Does he What does he want to lose elections? Is that
>> No, he's a he's a arrogant piece of
It's substantiated by reporting.
That like this guy actually rubs a ton of people the wrong way.
And he sort of he sort of got in and he was unex- he was not
expected to get in and he got in. Nobody really expected it and
that he kind of just an app- People don't really like him.
we're slated to have a historic
midterm coming up and we've outperformed
every prior
um off-season special election thing ever. Why is that?
>> Surely he's going to say why that is, right? You think
that's this guy spending money in Guam?
You think the money he threw into Guam is going to help? I It's
so baffling, man. It's so baffling. I don't even know what to
say. >> and if you can Martin be believed, last year was
the >> And again, all all you have to look at is the the
Dem
like think tanks and what they talked about in terms of of arrogance,
the arrogance of the party, the lack of transparency, this like
people don't you're not the party of the people. You've lost
the working class. You've lost all these people. They don't trust
you. And this guy gets up here and he does possibly the worst
thing you could It's like, "Hey, I'm going to tell you why we
lost. No, you don't get to see why we lost. I'm going to tell
you why we lost." He he is embodying the exact things the Democrats
were meant to move away from post 2024. His own lessons I'm positive,
right? I'm positive his own lessons are what he is he's embodying
the opposite of everything they're they're pitching to the
politicians to everyone going forward. Hey, we need to be more
relatable. We need to be more transparent. People need to trust
us again. We need to earn back trust. And he's doing the opposite.
>> the most successful fundraising year ever in the history
of the DNC. And all of that was accomplished by them ignoring
lessons and wanting to lose and being not aligned with the base.
What What the >> No, this guy just doesn't understand what
the base wants. He's not giving the base what they want. The
base wants
They do. They do. This is a part of it, man. And now do they
want transparency in terms of a post an after-action report on
the 2024 election? Not necessarily, but it is the essence of
they want a less arrogant, less disconnected Democratic Party.
And this guy is not representing those values at all. >> Are
we even saying here? What the Does this even mean?
There's some sort of goal that you have that's not in line and
will not be received well. Whether that is Israel-Palestine,
whether that's particular candidates, whether that's >> Oh,
yeah, there we go. >> AIPAC being >> primary challengers.
>> AIPAC I don't even know. I'm not even alleging anything.
But
I'm not even alleging anything. Israel-Palestine though >> I
mean, he added two other things in
Piscopo is saying it could be that, but it could be
specific candidates. It could be the Kamala Harris thing. It
could be that Biden was bad, right? I
The idea that we're like so Dude, look at the eyes, man. Look
at the eyes. He's like, man, I'm I'm
It's so weird. >> thing that came up there?
>> I'm not alleging anything. He's just asking questions.
You hear Mouton
chime in?
I'm surprised Mouton can get his head off of that for long enough
to get a word out, but apparently
>> Oh my god, he's just asking questions. He's just asking
questions.
>> I don't even know. I don't even know. Primary challengers,
I don't even know. I don't even allege anything, but
>> Primary challengers, I'm not even alleging anything.
He is I I don't know why in the world you would treat it like
this. Pisco is saying I don't know what's in there. Obviously,
he Ken Martin, there's something in there that Ken Martin thinks
releasing will cause infighting, right? He is saying it
>> I'm not even alleging anything with his real power.
>> Look at the eyes, man. This is a hutch moment right
here. >> Whether that's >> Oh, yeah. There we go.
>> Not Apex Apex Apex primary challengers, I don't even
know. I'm not even alleging anything, but
I'm not even alleging
>> Like look at the eyes. This is like a It's like disturbing,
right? It's disturbing to look at.
I can see the emptiness in his soul when I look into these eyes.
>> The report will be weaponized against >> He did
say that. Good job, Patriot Pete. And now he's going to be like
He's going to be like what what
What weapon? What?
Weaponize it? What?
But it's all in framing, right? Like Pisco believes that if you
put the information out, people will largely be able to action
off of it more than just like attack the Democrats with it,
That's what he wants. Pisco wants to action off of it, and he
doesn't trust these people. When you cover something
like I already did the hypothetical that it's like basically
if you have some Biden staffer who is responsible to talk to
the guy every day who knew that he was diminishing
and kept him in the race, you do not want that person near Democrat
politics.
And if that person would were being protected, hypothetically,
that is a
Right? That's an obvious disaster, and that's what people want
to avoid. That's what Fabro clearly thinks is happening
I don't know. Pisco is saying, "I don't really know which way
we would go on
Well, and the funny thing is is like Pisco has all the mental
tools to know this. And I know he did with that fancy law degree,
with that fancy job he was working in fancy New York City. How
many times have you told somebody
on the witness stand at a deposition when you're filing paperwork,
"Oh, just write like as much as you want." Like if they're asking
you a question, bro, it's a you've got all day. There's no time
limit on this. Yeah, be exhaustive. Cover every single base from
top to bottom. Why are we disconnecting this from the fact that
he said he would do exactly that? And that that was the the impetus
for having him for getting him elected. For for picking him as
DNC chair. That that was the promise he Well, like to we've totally
disconnected it from the fact that Ken Martin promised that he
would release this. >> There's parity there. The release
of the report will be weaponized against Democrats. The failure
to release will be weaponized against Democrats. >> Oh,
he's he's so close. Oh, it's almost like it's a lose-lose. I
mean, that's That is an excuse never to release any kind of autopsy.
>> True, which is why Ken Martin should have said it, you
idiot. >> It proves too much. Maybe this particular report
is bad, but then just tell why. Like this will be weaponized
>> What do you mean you can't say why? That's the whole
point of not releasing it. If he tells you why they feel like
it would be damaging if they released it, then that means that
they can't really then that means they would just release it.
Listen to what he said. >> reason people take the wrong
inferences is because this data
insert thing here. I don't know, man. This is >> How wicked
he's saying, "I don't want to release it because I think people
because there's something in here about like trans people and
we're worried that if we release it people are going to look
at trans people the wrong way." Thank you, Ken Martin, for saying
that. So, now we all know not to blame trans people. Or they're
going to look at the Israel-Palestine issue and they're you know,
it might have moved the needle in like one state a little bit.
So, we >> He just has to release it now. He literally doesn't
have the option to release it. It could say that actually every
single major Democrat Democratic president ever is a and prove
it with videos and they should still release it.
You're you're it's just honestly going to be used against you
it like forever
You you ran on it. You got to release it or step down. Release
it, or step down. Those are your options. That's it. That's it.
You said you would release it. You're now saying you won't release
it. Step down, or release it. If somebody else comes in, if a
second set of eyes comes in, and they go, "Oh, actually we um
we totally should have we should totally shouldn't release this."
Then maybe.
But my goodness, man.
>> Like it's so funny. He's talking about releasing an
autopsy, and then nobody will take it the wrong way, and we can't
even agree on George Floyd's autopsy, even though he's on top
sitting on his neck for 10 minutes, okay? Like what a stupid
And And it's not even that It's not even that we're disagreeing
over whatever. It's that he can't even fathom He can't even imagine
>> That's wow. Wow, what a great Oh my god, this guy's
like a What a beautiful mind, man. What a beautiful mind. This
guy made that connection. That's so cool.
a bad inference.
2024 election. The point being fingers to place blame to to to
I mean, you want to learn lessons, like you said. Well, listen,
hey, you know, sometimes it's important to place blame, actually.
It's actually sometimes important to place blame.
And to realize who we should trust, who we shouldn't trust, who
we should
go with, who shouldn't go with, what ideas are working, and what
ideas are not working.
So, in elections that you want to win elections, you want to
win elections, you want Theoretically. Well, but I mean, we don't
really know they know it. We would have to check and see like
how they're performing in elections. Oh, they're doing historically
well. Oh, we'd have to see how they're doing with their fundraising.
Oh, well, they're doing historically well. >> Historic
highs. >> Not historic highs.
>> And And I got to go to the lessons learned. I got to
go to the Anyone who wants to talk All right, let's just move
on. I mean, he's not going to get any more questions. >> So,
what are the [__] lessons >> Well, what I'm
not going to do is release a report that turns everyone backwards
to either point fingers or place blame. >> Oh, and Pisco
even kind of stumbles onto it, cuz again, I don't think Pisco's
intentional here. He just lacks the political savvy to know what
role he's
>> Yeah, Destiny literally didn't understand anything about
this
Um he's a complete [__] [__] I'm talking
about political savvy with Pisco. I just don't It's
Oh, it's painful. It's painful to listen to, right? Like you
see somebody who's a complete idiot, and they make a bunch of
money off of doing this. They're really bad at it. They're just
unspeakably
bad at their job, complete [__] They're condescending
to everybody else. Ugh, it's no wonder everybody is psyched for
this guy to fall off. Like, no wonder so many people dislike
this person. There is nothing likable or redeemable here. He's
totally unlikable
>> That would have been Did I don't think John actually
asked that question. That actually would have been a good question,
wouldn't it have been? Well, what were Yeah, what were some of
the lessons? What are you talking to other politicians about?
That would actually would be a good question. Now,
John knows that. John John is annoyed with this guy for not doing
what he said he was going to do. John knows what the lessons
are that they're putting out. >> I wonder if he's always
going to get upset that John never actually asks anything besides
this one point that he was trying to crucify Ken Martin on. >> Actually,
ignore that. >> The point Ken come on The point Ken came
on to discuss. >> own responsibility helping us to fix
the situation. The reality is is, you know, we all have a responsibility,
yourself, myself, everyone in actually learning those lessons,
focusing on upcoming election, putting them into action, so we
don't have to do this That's what we've been talking about John.
I'm going to bring up strategies who's run for the party told
the Washington Examiner that there's a quote financial penalty
specifically tied to burying the autopsy. >> I'm not He
won't let it go. Respect to Favreau, he really won't let it go.
I mean,
>> Respect Now, when Ken was standing 10 toes down, it
was, "Man, Ken hates this guy." Okay, Ken hates this guy. Man,
he's being really hostile. He's being real mean. That was or
he's What is he saying? He's being really mean. Ken hates this
guy. But, when John, who by the way, John just accused Ken Martin
of basically being bribed for burying the autopsy. That's what
John just accused Ken Martin of. He's accused me of being bribed.
There's a financial incentive for you guys to not release the
autopsy, which what the >> Yeah, this is why you don't
play video games try to do politics at the same time, cuz he
just misunderstood massively again in the precise opposite way
of what was actually said. He's a
He's just a totally detestable,
disgusting
predators freak idiot. He just has There's no redeemable qualities
here, man. There's nothing. There's nothing going on that's redeemable.
He got it perfectly backwards. So, he said, "Oh, he he accuses
him of taking a bribe." Like there's a financial incentive for
not releasing.
Except one,
John's quoting reporting. And two, that's the opposite of what
he >> Uh so, Steve Schale, um long-time Democratic strategist
who's run Florida for the party, told the Washington Examiner
that there's a quote financial penalty specifically tied to burying
the autopsy because donors want a clear accounting before re-committing
the de-
>> Obvious, true statement.
Donors want an accounting before they re-commit their money.
It is not a bribe, you
It is the donors don't want to give money to people who are going
to mismanage those funds.
Hey, idiots. You got it totally wrong again. Please, be more
condescending
to Pisco and anybody else covering this who actually pay attention
instead of playing video games like a child in the background.
Okay, listen again. >> specifically tied to burying the
autopsy >> Oh my god. He won't let it go. Respect to Favreau,
he really won't let it go. I mean
Respect. Now, when Ken
The By the way, that that blows out everything Destiny said before
this, too, because what John Favreau's talking about is big money
donors, right? So, Destiny's totally put John Favreau in this
lefty camp who don't like big donors. That's not John Favreau.
John Favreau's the Obama guy. Obama are the corporate Dems, okay?
The Obama guys are the corporate Dems. They're the guys who love
big money donors. They're the guys who try to take care of big
money
He's talking about big money donors wanting proof that their
money's not going to be mismanaged before they re-commit to the
party?
And Destiny interprets this as Apparently, Ken Martin is like
taking a bribe. Incredible, incredible stuff, man. Withstanding
10 toes down, it was Man, Ken hates this guy, right? Remember,
underlying facts are all the same, okay? Ken hates this guy.
Man, he's being really hostile. He's being real mean. That was
or he's What do you say? He's being really mean. Ken hates this
guy. But when John, who by the way, John just accused Ken Martin
of basically being bribed for burying the autopsy. That's what
John just accused
>> Not even remotely. You can't even remotely hear what
was said and interpret it that way. I assume Did somebody in
his chat say that? Did so Is somebody telling him what to to
say here? I don't even know. It's the exact opposite of what
was said.
That's again
I can't put this to you any other way than I would never watch
this if it was just Destiny seething about one of his friends
who doesn't like anymore. I It's the political analysis is so
offensive and so off point. It's so
gross listening to this guy be arrogant while being wrong about
everything, man. And And then you get Mr. Brunette trying to
get in the sides to Oh, It don't be like that, Mr. Brunette.
It don't be like that, Mr. Brunette.
>> Ken Martin accused me of being bribed. There's a financial
incentive for you guys to not release the autopsy, which what
the [__] does that even mean? Why the [__]
would they commit This is like when people say that Kubrick was
killed for the 30 minutes of secret footage at the end of Eyes
Wide Shut or whatever. Like all of Hollywood was okay with letting
him film, you know, something that would have brought >> going
off on some
reference, I guess, to try to make this make sense even though
it's what he said. I'm sorry, I can't give Pisco the benefit
of ignorance of political savviness. Well, we constantly find
ourselves here. I don't know. Dude, they're arrogant and they're
like they're actually They have their noses out of joint at how
evil Pisco's being when they're totally wrong about everything
going on. It's such a [__] embarrassing cult,
Uh maybe that's the cope on my end is like I used to chat in
this in that chat. It's like, "Dude, you guys have to be Right?
Like I There's no way I used to chat in that chat. There's no
way I used to be a part of that in any way whatsoever, and it's
just this bad. It's this embarrassing, right? Like, please stop
being so embarrassing, but they can't. They can't stop being
this embarrassing, man. >> And so, my point My point to
you My point to you is this, John, okay? I mean, we can trade
in all these but let's actually trade in facts. $105 million
was raised. $85 million of it came from grassroots donors, which
is a record amount of grassroots donations raised in the history
of the Democratic Party. That it shows the energy that's out
there. The average contribution is >> Yeah, there's energy
out there. I mean, I hope that if that's true, that's encouraging.
I actually saw reporting that um it's not such a rosy picture
when it comes to um sort of the main line funding entities. But
maybe maybe that reporting is is wrong. >> Okay, but now,
I don't know if Pisco's a big paid-to-the-donor-class type person,
but like
think about what he just said there.
So, Ken Martin just said, "We've had a record amount of small
cash donations for this last uh fundraising cycle, where we outraised
the DNC >> Surely, surely Destiny's going to think about
what he said there, too, right? >> See, uh at all points
in history. It's the most successful what quarter of year ever.
Majority was small cash donations. >> No, not most of No,
no. No.
For the first year of a new chair, as in he he the bar you should
measure Ken against, he's saying when the chair first comes in,
they're not used to raising money, they're not very good at raising
money, they don't have the connections yet. So, in the first
year, they have a bad year.
That's what he's talking about.
It's the first
year. Okay? >> has most ever. And then Pisco's like Pisco's
like, "What about the donor class, though? What about the big
line major donors, though? What about What about the big donors,
though? Like would that object >> again brings it up with
the I So, this is Destiny's so brain-broken on Hasan and the
lefties and the populace that he doesn't realize that that's
what everybody else sees. Like, Pisco almost certainly knows
that John Favreau's an Obama guy. He's a corporate dem, right?
He is >> Yeah. Jon Favreau is like sort of essence of He's
He's like anti-Cenk. That's who Jon Favreau is, right? He's
I know that's that's confusing, but Pisco probably understands
that. A lot of people understand that, right?
Destiny can't fathom it. Destiny doesn't get it. He's He's warped
his brain so much around this Hasan conspiracy that he thinks
it's all about Hasan. He thinks it's all about like, I don't
know, overthrowing democracy for communists. I can't even tell.
Yes, nobody's mad at big donors. Everybody wants the Democrats
to have lots of money from lots of big donors. It's what everyone
wants. >> jection be brought up ever in any other
>> No, they wouldn't give a [__] >> What
about the donors?
The big donors.
I know that >> Only the The answer there is only people
who want to win would bring that up.
Only people who want to win, man. That's it. That's only people
who want to win would bring up the donors. That's clearly what
Jon Favreau's talking about the whole time. By the way, Destiny
did not connect with that at all when he watched it by himself,
right?
Destiny could not fathom that Jon Favreau was upset because big
money donors are not approaching the Democrats. He didn't get
it. He didn't understand it. Couldn't fathom it because he's
got Hasan's in his ear. >> Right, I'm going to read the
report. 13.9 million cash on hand, 18.3 million in debt. So,
that's roughly negative 4.4 million dollars. And I know it's
a private party power, but the DSCC and the DCCC and these Senate
candidates have plenty of money. They're all doing great. So,
it seems like this is a this is an issue unique to the DNC. >> That's
not accurate, Jon. Listen to The reality is we're spending money
as we raise it to win elections and to build infrastructure.
We have invested >> So, what's not accurate? Are his numbers
>> Numbers are totally correct. Jon doesn't say the thing
here that he's that he's im- that he's implying, right? The thing
that Jon's upset about is, again, one last time, we're 6 months
away from the midterms, we've got no money for the most crucial
part of the election. We've not built a war chest in any way.
We will only be able to spend what we've raised in those like
couple lead-up months. That's That's crazy. What are we going
to do?
It's like bordering on a five-alarm fire, right? Like we are
we are about we're just about in freak-out >> You can say
like no, I mean those numbers are right, but we're doing it because
we want to win races and we are winning races, John, or something
like something. But just saying is not accurate. You're basically
saying Okay, Favreau's an idiot. Favreau's making all this [__]
up. Yeah, you're part of the problem.
>> That is what Ken Martin said.
Of course, the one point where Destiny could possibly
go, "Hey, Pisco is wrong here." He is in a trance, in a zone,
playing a video
This is your hero. This is your guy. This is your This is your
number one guy. This is your dude right here. He's playing a
video game. He can actually point out, "Hey, Pisco actually is
saying something that Ken Martin already
If you were paying attention, if you were listening, if you weren't
just playing a video game cuz you're worthless as a political
commentator. Yeah, okay. All right. >> I mean like yeah,
he kind of has been. Yeah, he's kind of [__] up a
lot of [__] in here.
Nobody's saying everything is good and everything is perfect
or whatever else,
>> That was him saying
uh that Jon Favreau's bad, by the way, not calling out Pisco.
You know.
>> What Yeah, what the [__] does he know? Condescending,
man. Say what's not >> He has He has He's corrected him
like 20 times.
>> Bring up a new topic. >> It's very important that
John John The thing John [__] up here is he's not
saying the big thing, which is we need money to spend on ads.
We need money to spend on in those couple months. Basically,
the the back-and-forth where this should have been brought in
is when Ken says, "We are
Oh, what does Ken say? He's like, "We need to spend money early.
Oh, it's Oh, the conventional wisdom is you wait until the 3
months before the election to spend money and we think that's
You need to say, "Okay, but you should have some money. You should
be saving some money for that point. You can't just spend all
of your money. If you have no money going into those months,
you have no way to figure out where you're like actually struggling
and to readjust in those moments, right? 3 months before the
election is where you know where you need to spend money. Otherwise,
you're just spending it like basically in places you don't have
to, Like, hey, you're spending money in Guam, but Guam actually
votes Democrat
Okay, so you could spend that maybe take the money out of Guam
and put it in Pennsylvania or something, right? That's the thing
is when you wait until closer to the election, you have more
of an understanding of where you need to spend the money. Important.
You need to hand-picked. Someone made this interview to trigger
me as much as possible.
Someone specifically designed this to make me as furious as possible
given his conduct. It's crazy. You know, we have our local listener
program that's already engaging through your own organizing those
voters who dropped off in 2024. You have to spend money to win
elections. And one of the lessons we learned is if we wait Now,
look, I know you came up in a certain time and and day in politics,
but the old conventional wisdom, John, it doesn't fly anymore.
Condescending. You came up in a certain time. The old way, bro.
>> I'm pretty sure I well, I don't actually know it, but
is Ken Martin older than
>> He looks older. >> Yeah, wait. I These What do
you Come on, >> I'm pretty sure I well, I don't actually
know it, but is Ken Martin older than
>> He looks older. >> Yeah, wait. I These What do
you Come on, bro? Holy [__]
>> You guys He seems younger than you a And you're basically
saying he's stuck in his ways and so he's taking shots at Favreau.
Favreau who >> Favreau literally accused him earlier of
accepting of financial incentives to bury the autopsy, bro.
>> Yeah, so again, um that's Destiny's point. That is obviously
wrong. He's completely wrong there. Again,
total [__] can't listen, playing video games instead
of listening, trying to provide political analysis, got a zombie
army, total trillions in the >> Peace Corps is an actual
stalker, lol.
>> Just brain-damaged losers who have nothing else By the
way, that is I and I I don't want to get like too offensive here,
but that's what these people are. They are sad, lonely losers
who have nothing better. They can't do anything else with their
lives, so they show up here to get some sense of fulfillment.
Unfortunately for them, Destiny is no longer any sort of fulfilling
person to follow. He doesn't give you good ideas. He doesn't
equip you to have arguments. He does nothing of value or use.
You guys are just being farmed for money and you're too sad to
look at this and understand it. You're just far too sad as people.
The The reason you're back there is because you saw him do something
that really annoyed
and you left and then you slowly realized that you couldn't build
anything in life for yourself. You had nothing that you could
do that gave you any amount of fulfillment and you ended up back
in an internet chat spending most of your time there. Very sad.
Very, very sad, okay? Nothing else you can possibly do, man.
>> This is not a way to convince people.
And I know because this is the kind of [__] that
I like to do. And I very often when I'm in these debates, you
know, I'm not convincing tons of people uh because they especially
in like real time you're not going to by confronting them and
and paying off it's just because I like to do it. I I like to
be clear and I like to be analytical about how we do it, but
I I'm not convinced that my style or or being confrontational
like this is the best way to actually convince your interlocutor.
No, no, I think it's great that you're spending money early and
I think it's very important to invest in >> He's like rolling
his eyes. >> big parties I think campaign strategy is extremely
important. But we're talking about different things. We're talking
about spending money and raising money and you raise 11.4 >> Also,
by the way, he's not rolling his eyes. He's It looks like he's
got Ken on a uh monitor up here in order to maintain eye contact,
but he's got to look down at his laptop for his talking points
for his hit piece. That's what's going on here, by the way.
You can watch the interaction. >> No, no, I think it's
great that you're spending money early and I >> He's talking
to the monitor because Ken Martin must be uh in front of him
uh uh stage right in front of him. >> I think it's very
important to invest in >> He's like rolling his eyes. >> The
hit piece. I think wouldn't he just be like the sources he had
for the interview? Wouldn't he write his script, Destiny, of
course, you know, infamously showed up to
what is it? The The interview with two Scientologists, the daughter
of the head of Scientology,
right? On Bridges. They had the daughter of the head of Scientology
on Bridges. Destiny showed up and at some point about an hour
into the interview, he asked the woman, "So, do you have any
family left in Scientology at all?"
Destiny has no concept of studying or coming prepared to anything.
He's a complete loser, again.
>> He parties, I think it's >> Now, he looks at the
camera cuz he remembers to look at the camera. Then, he's looking
down as he's talking about his
>> But, we're talking about two different things. We're
talking about spending money and raising money, and you raised
>> He looked up to see him in the monitor. >> 11.4
million dollars in >> Down to his talking points. Camera's
in front of him. It's kind of an awkward setup, but It's just
funny that he's like, "Oh, he rolled his eyes." Bro. >> that
in March. And so, if you're going to spend that much money, obviously,
you have to also raise the money, too, because otherwise, the
difference between investment and just outrunning your costs
and taking out a loan because of that is
>> It's not outrunning our costs here because we're able
to make these investments all throughout the country. >> And
race after race in our in our state party infrastructure, in
our local party >> You know, if we weren't able to to keep
up in terms of building out this infrastructure, then there would
be a problem. We won over 90% of the elections on the ballot,
and most of them, if not all of them, we had a direct involvement
in. And I just say this to you, John, because, you know, it was
a bet we made. And I get it. You know, again, all of it folks
>> what they like to they seem obsessed
They they >> a lot of time thinking about it, and most
of them, if not all of them, we had a direct involvement in.
And I just say this to you, John, because, you know, it was a
bet we made. And I get it. You know, again, all of it folks in
DC, what they like to >> they they seem obsessed about
they They they a lot of time thinking >> He was literally
a speech writer for Obama, bro. Are you saying these aren't DC
Where is the Pod Save studio at? Are they in DC? Or are they
in LA?
Wait, is that what he accused him of being obsessed about? >> 90%
of the elections on the ballot, and most of them, if not all
of them, we had a direct >> And I just say this to you,
John, because, you know, it was a bet we made. And I get You
know, again, all of it folks in DC, what they like to >> they
they seem obsessed about They they a lot of time thinking about
it. How much time do you >> He was literally a speech writer
for Obama, bro.
>> Why are you disagreeing? It's already goofy. Pisco's
just making fun of the
We don't even know what Ken's actually saying they're obsessed
about yet, and Destiny's disagreeing to defend Ken. We actually
We haven't even heard what Ken is saying people are obsessed
with, and Destiny is disagreeing to try to fight Pisco. You You
catch that, right?
That Pisco's making fun of this guy for using the word obsessed
in the exact way Destiny has multiple times made fun of people
for saying the word as if it's a way to sort of minimize other
people's concern, right? You're just obsessed with this, man.
You're so obsessed with this. You're just so obsessed, dude.
And Dest- We haven't even heard. Now
Now Destiny's defending the use of obsessed because he's an Obama
bro?
The funny thing is is actually I think Destiny's going to be
correct here, but he has no idea why he's going to be correct,
which is super funny. Are we really still talking Are we really
still talking about Obama in 2026? Also, it's funny that he's
talking about the Obama bro thing because that's critical to
understanding this interview, and he didn't understand it before.
Must have read it in chat.
>> No, because No, it was a bet we made. And I get it.
You know, again, all of the folks in DC, what they like to they
seem obsessed about obsessed they a lot of time thinking about
is how much >> He was literally a speech writer for Obama,
bro. Are you saying >> I don't know what What are we even
disagreeing with here? What could you be disagreeing with? What
What is Destiny thinks coming up that that he's going to disagree
with? What does he think here? He doesn't even know what the
actual statement is yet.
>> Like these aren't DC bro- Where is the Pod Save America
studio at? Are they in DC? Are they in LA? What do
Does he think that Pisco is saying they're not DC bros?
Pisco's laughing at the use of obsessed.
Destiny's just trying to spaz. Bro, he
Stop playing the video game, man. Just stop playing the video
game. You're embarrassing yourself repeatedly. Stop playing the
video game. It's sad. It's sad to watch. Was this on there in
person? I don't remember.
But if this was if the political teams were changed here, people
would be like, "Epic, he owned him. Oh my god, he owned him so
hard." Again, he thinks it's team sports. He thinks Favreau and
Hasan are on the same team or something.
He He literally doesn't understand the situation at all. He just
sees like an opportunity to spaz, so he's going to spaz again.
Right? He just doesn't get it. He literally doesn't understand.
But if this was if the political teams were changed here, people
would be like, "Epic, he owned him. Oh my god, he owned him so
hard, bro. He owned him with the facts there. But he's supposed
to be like a submissive, breedable, bent over, like get by these
weirdo commie losers.
Probably just not supposed to lie about releasing the report
and then continue to lie about stuff. That's probably more more
of piece where he's coming from, I'm guessing.
These commie losers. I guess Jon Favreau's a commie loser. Maybe
Pisco's a commie loser. I'm not sure which one's a commie here.
I don't know which one's more laughable, the the like turbo lib
lawyer or the corporate dem Obama bro.
And in terms of them either of them being communists. Like I
It's so goofy, man. It's so goofy.
He can't make an argument. He can't even He can't raise a complaint.
He can't make an argument. He's just spamming the communist button
now. He's cut to red scare tactics.
Well, worked on my parents, I guess. owned him. Oh my god, he
owned him so hard, bro. He owned him with the facts there. But
he's supposed to be like a submissive, breedable, bent over,
like get by these weirdo Kami losers. Oh my god, I'm so triggered
by it. Dude, it's okay.
>> You're so triggered He just gave up halfway. He couldn't
even make an argument. He just said Kami. He basically just said
Kami and then gave
These guys are Kami losers. I'm just
I'm just >> It's so embarrassing, man. >> Did you
refer to the Pod Save either Pisco or the Pod Save guys are Kami's?
I think he's referring to John Favreau is a Kami.
The Obama
staffer, corporate dem, who's arguing on behalf of the massive
corporate donors in this conversation
is a Kami.
He's a Kami.
Uh-huh. Yeah, huh?
>> just a misfiguring trying to play a Gotcha journalist
here and he's getting facts wrong, Pisco. It kind of matters,
but
>> It feels like well, he it wasn't just a trying to play
a Gotcha journalist here and he's getting facts wrong, Pisco.
It kind of matters, but
>> Probably what he's hinting at is there's some reporting
that they bought this voter file or this fundraising list, right?
They bought it and then they might have overpaid for it slightly
Kamala's campaign had some debts left over. And so I think I
think there's like some reporting
that they Yeah, they basically overpaid for it to pay off some
of Kamala's debts, right? >> It is concerns me that I see
two things. One, this autopsy which you campaigned on releasing
and and I know you're releasing things, but are hiding still
plenty of the details in the autopsy. I just can't figure out
what details are in there that you don't
I I mean Why do you think he's going to He's not going to budge
on this, Favored. I mean, they just >> Even Pisco recognizes,
but he's like kind of being a memer softball by oh, he's not
going to budge. Like, does Pisco not recognize that asking repeatedly
the same question over and over and over again is like a hardcore
debate push? Like, you're This is like a very, very, very >> And
so much of this analysis is just undone by the first like 30
seconds of this conversation. >> Quick bit of context for
listeners. This all came about because you expressed some frustration
about criticism of the DNC coming from our direction, so I appreciate
you coming on to talk about it directly. >> The entire
premise for the conversation is Pod Save guys mad at the DNC,
DNC guy mad at the Pod Save guys for being mad at the DNC. It
is going to be a hostile conversation It's going to be a contentious
conversation from the